[MUSIC PLAYING]
AYLIN ALTIOK: Hello, everyone.
We are very excited to
have you all here today.
My name is Aylin, and
I'm a product manager
for Actions on Google.
NICK FELKER: And
I'm Nick Felker.
I'm a developer programs
engineer for the Google
Assistant and IoT.
AYLIN ALTIOK:
Today, we will talk
about best practices
for testing your actions
and the tools we have built
to make it easier for you.
But before getting
into details I
want to mention why
testing is so important.
It's important because
your users care about it.
How do w know that?
By looking at f reviews,
we noticed 42% of the users
mention app stability and
bugs in their one-star review.
And 62% of the users
uninstall the app
if they notice crash,
freeze, or an error.
On the flip side,
though, 73% of the users
mention speed,
design, and usability
in their five-star review.
So this tells us users
want five-star apps.
And this has been
the trend we have
been seeing in mobile world.
And it's no different
when it comes to actions.
So today, we will walk you
through some tips and tools
that will let you build
your own five-star actions.
Our journey today
starts with Jane.
Jane is a Node.js developer.
She works in a startup, and she
wants to build her own action.
Her action is
called Trail Blazer.
And Trail Blazer will
return nearby bike trails
for a given user location.
So together, we'll start our
journey designing and building
Trail Blazer with Dialogflow.
Then we will test it
locally by using simulator.
And we'll show you how you
can write your own unit
test for your actions by using
automated testing library.
And we'll show you how
you can test your actions
with your own users by
using alpha and beta release
environments.
This is something we
just announced yesterday,
and we are super excited to
show you the details later today
in this session.
And once you deploy our
action to production,
we'll show you some tools
like health analytics
and Stackdriver logging to
make sure your actions remain
healthy throughout
the lifecycle.
Awesome.
Let's start with
design and build.
So we'll do that
with Dialogflow.
Dialogflow enables you to
build rich conversational
experiences.
How does it do that?
It gives you major language
processing out of the box.
So it takes unstructured
user response,
and it automatically matches
that to intents and entities
you defined.
And you can handle this
in your own server.
So as a developer,
you don't need
to worry about
knowing or writing
your own machine
learning models.
It just works for you
if you use Dialogflow.
Let's see what it
means for Trail Blazer.
So as you can see,
Dialogflow sits
in between Assistant
server and your own server.
So for Trail Blazer, we
use Google Cloud Platform
to build our own server logic.
So when user says,
talk to Trail Blazer,
Assistant server
takes that response,
and takes our welcome
intent from Dialogflow,
and returns back to user.
So after that
point, user may say,
find me nearby bike trails,
or where are the nearby bike
trails, and multiple other
variations of these type
of text responses.
And then Dialogflow
automatically
matches that to
intent we defined.
Let's call it find trails.
And that intent may be reading
the logic from our own server.
Our own server, we may
have the location services,
we find the trails, and
we respond back to user.
And we don't need to worry about
nature of language processing.
NICK FELKER: Thank you.
So now you've built your action.
How do you start testing it?
Well, the first step
is to use the Actions
on Google simulator.
And this works on your
laptop or your desktop.
And you also test on your device
if you have a Home or a phone.
You can enter text or
you can just talk to it.
And you'll get the
response that you expect.
And you can do extra things,
like changing the user's
language and their location.
How does this work?
Let's go to the demo.
All right, let's go to the demo
and click on the Simulator tab
here.
I'm going to jump right
here into the action.
We're going to say,
talk to Trail Blazer.
All right.
We can say, find trails nearby.
You notice, I did
make a typo there,
but Dialogflow is going
to be able to map it
to the intent regardless.
And you can look, we have
a Request and Response
tab on the side.
And that will help you
debug your actions.
We'll say yes,
show the location.
You notice in the
top right corner,
I've actually mapped it to
my hometown of Glassboro.
So you can actually show the
different types of locations
as well.
In the Display tab,
you notice that it
has picked park that is pretty
close to where I used to live.
And that's a very basic overview
of how the simulator works.
Let's go back to the
slides for a second.
So you can do this and mainly
test your actions every time
you make a change.
But as actions grow
more complicated,
you want to make sure
that users continue
to have a reliable experience.
And to make this easier,
we're introducing
the automated testing library
for Actions on Google.
So if you're familiar
with Node.js,
then you'll be familiar with
using this testing library.
It's written with Node.js.
It supports all of the
Actions on Google locales.
And it works with your existing
testing infrastructure,
whether that's [INAUDIBLE]
or continuous integration.
All those things
work out of the box.
So there's three key
features that this library
will do for developers.
First, you can send text
queries to your action.
And this can be unstructured
queries, exactly what
the user would say.
And this is important,
because users can say anything
to your conversation,
and you want to make sure
that you can handle that.
You're going to get
back SSML, text,
rich responses, and everything
else that you would expect.
And it uses your account
to send the queries.
So things like user
storage and the last time
you visited the action
will be exactly what
it would be for yourself.
How is this going to work
for you as a developer?
Let's switch over to the
demo, and I'll show you.
So you notice I've got
this test.js file here.
And we will just go down.
So first we import the library.
And we're going
to instantiate it.
We're going to pass in
my user credentials.
So it's going to talk to
this action as myself.
And we start a test.
And we get to test a name.
We can also set things
like the location.
So we can change the location
and see how the action performs
in different areas.
And then we're going
to start by returning
a promise that will start the
conversation with Trail Blazer.
We're going to go out and send
this query, find trails nearby.
And then we're going to send yes
after it asks for our location.
You make sure you also try
no and test different flows
with different permissions.
At the very end, we're
going to get back text
to speech and chords.
And you can do assertions
to verify that those
are exactly what we'd expect.
At the very end,
you end the test.
How does this work?
Let's go over here
and run npm test.
OK, so now we've
started our test.
And in a few seconds, it's going
to send talk to Trail Blazer.
And we're going to
get back a response.
OK.
And you see a variety of
parameters in that response.
Is the mic open, text to
speech, SSML cards, et cetera.
OK, so we send
found trails nearby.
We're going to get
back that thing.
It's going to to ask for our
permission to use our location.
We'll say yes.
OK, and then at the end,
you see we've got the card,
we've got the text,
and everything else
from our action.
At the very bottom, you see
that it says, one test passes.
All right, there you go.
So using this tool, you will
be able to more easily verify
that your actions do
exactly what you'd expect.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
AYLIN ALTIOK: Awesome.
So far, we built Trail Blazer,
and we tested it locally
in our simulator.
And we wrote our own
unit test, and made
sure they were all green.
But it is always
important as a developer
to test your actions
with your own users.
Why?
Because they may find
bugs and usability
issues that you didn't
think or you didn't catch.
Let's see how you can do it
by utilizing our new alpha
and beta release environments.
So alpha is the quickest
way to test your actions.
Once you submit
alpha, it doesn't
go through the review process.
So it can be live just
in a couple hours.
And you can invite your friends,
family, and your teammates
up to 20 testers.
And you can iterate by
releasing alpha, and acting
on the feedback from your
users, and keep this iteration
going on until you have
the stable version.
And once you have
the stable version,
you can submit that
for beta release.
Beta is live after going through
regular Google review process.
So your actions
would be live if that
are approved after the review.
But once they are
approved, you don't
need to go through
additional review
to deploy those to production.
So as a developer,
you can decide
to deploy this to
a public audience
at your own flexible timing.
And you can invite
wider audience
for your beta release,
up to 200 users.
Awesome.
Let's see how that
works in action.
Let's go back to demo mode.
Perfect.
So let's take it from where
we left off in simulator.
So now you can see
a new release tab
in the left-hand side navigation
in the Actions console.
Let's go ahead and click that.
And you'll see, aside
from production,
we also have now alpha
and beta release.
These are totally optional.
You don't need to utilize those.
But since you are in
the session today,
I'm sure you care about
testing our actions
with your own users.
And before getting into
the details of alpha,
I just want to show you
the versions I already
deployed before.
So currently, I have
three different versions--
once in alpha, once in beta,
and once in production--
that is already
deployed to my users.
So let's go ahead and
deploy an alpha together.
But before doing so, let's
change something in our actions
so we can tell our users if
they like the new change.
So now you see the actions
under the build section.
I'll go ahead and click that.
And if you are familiar
with the Action console,
you may notice that we just
redesigned the whole UI for you
to make it easier
for your navigation.
So we'll see our
default welcome intent
here that we already
built with Dialogflow.
I'll click on that, and
it gives me the option
to edit that in Dialogflow.
Let's see how that looks like.
So this is my welcome
intent, but we also
have other interns that I
mentioned to you before that we
can handle in our server.
So I'll go back and go to
default welcome intent.
So right now, our welcome
message to the users
says, good day
from Trail Blazer.
Let's change that and let's
see if our alpha testers
would like it.
So instead of Trail
Blazer, let's say,
good day from Google
IO stage seven.
So I'll save this.
And after it is
saved, I can go ahead
and see how that works by
clicking the right-hand side.
And this is going
to bring my draft
version into the simulator to
see the changes that I just
did.
So let's see talk
to Trail Blazer.
And let's make sure it's
reading from the draft.
Let's try it again.
Awesome.
So it says, good day from Google
IO stage seven, as we expected.
So we want to test it
with our alpha users,
and see if they're going to
like this response instead
of the previous version.
And also please
note that you can
see all your versions
here and test
them to see the difference.
So I'll just click down.
I'll go ahead and click
on the release tab now.
And on the release tab,
let's push this version
into our alpha testers.
So while my production
on beta remains
like a different
outcome that says,
welcome come to Trail
Blazer, our alpha
is going to be
taking this version
and changing the
welcome response.
So we just need to click that
we tested it in simulator,
we've gone through
the checklist,
and we are complying
with policies.
And once we submit,
this is going
to run our pre-submit
checks, and we'll
be done in a few seconds.
And while it is doing that--
oh, it's already done.
So you can see now
that our version
will be in deploying state.
Perfect.
So we created version seven.
And now it's being in
the deploying state.
And it will be deployed
just in a few hours
and live to your testers.
But how do we invite
our own testers?
You'll see a Manage
Alpha Testers.
And same applies to
beta, by the way.
The only difference
if we did beta,
we would see the
status as under review.
So we'll go ahead and
click on Manage Testers.
So in this section, you
can add your own testers
to make sure they
are whitelisted
to receive your alpha version.
So we can just add
this to my list.
And I already had some
other emails before.
And once I hit Save,
All these users
are listed to get
my alpha version.
Just a couple
things to note here.
The users you are adding should
have Wallet Google account,
either Gmail or
Google Apps user.
Otherwise, you would see
that a validation would fail,
and you can't remove
and add the new users.
So the last step as
a developer for you
is to invite your own testers.
So you see in here,
there is an opt in link.
And this is a static
link that directs users
to your directory page.
So if your users are
already using your action
in their mobile, they can
just search your action name,
like Trail Blazer, and they
would see your invitation
in the action directed page.
But if they are not
familiar with that,
you can just share this link.
And once they click this
link on their mobile phone,
either iOS or Android, they
would land into your directory.
Let's see how that
experience looks like.
Let's go back to our slides.
Perfect.
So we now created
an alpha release,
and we took the opt in link,
shared with our tester.
So the first thing here
is the place they land in.
So this is my action
directory page on mobile.
And when they scroll
down, they see
that the invitation that
I added them to my beta,
or same applies to alpha.
And once they are all OK to be
your alpha tester, they say,
I'm in.
And after that point,
they will start
talking to your test version.
And at any time,
they can opt out
or they can switch
between alpha and beta
if you invited them
to both channels.
How cool is that?
This feature was a
top developer quest,
and we are so excited to
actually make it happen.
So let's recap what we
have been doing so far.
So Jane builds her Trail
Blazer action with Dialogflow.
She tested locally
with simulator,
and also she was able to test
it with her own device that
was connected to
her preview account.
And she wrote her unit test
by using automated testing
library.
And once everything was green,
she moved it to her teammates
and made an alpha release.
Her teammates gave
her feedback, and she
was able to iterate and make
her actions more stable.
And then she released
it to her beta testers
to a more wider audience.
And once she made sure
her actions were stable,
she's ready to go
for production.
But before going
to production, I
would like to share some
best practices while you
are testing your actions.
So as a developer,
we always think
about end-to-end journeys, and
trying to capture those use
cases in our test.
But what does it even mean
in a conversational space?
So in Assistant world, your
users may be in multiple modes.
And these modes are
determined by input and output
of your device.
So if a user is talking to a
Trail Blazer in Google Home,
they would only get voice.
But if they're talking to Trail
Blazer on their mobile phone,
not only they would get
voice, but they would also
get image of the
nearby bike trails.
So as a developer, it's
important to think about where
our users may be interacting
with our actions,
and handle these test
cases accordingly
to make sure their experience
is smooth in all devices
that actions are offered.
And the second
important point is
to make sure your users are
able to enter your actions.
So it's good to test
your invocations.
They can invoke your
app in multiple ways,
either explicitly by saying,
talk to a Trail Blazer,
ask Trail Blazer,
or you may also
have some built-in intents or
some implicit invocation that
may be triggered in a different
way, let's say, play a game
or find the nearby bike trails.
So actions on Google today are
offered in multiple languages.
And it becomes even
more important to test
your users' languages in
a conversational world.
So this is a great one to be
able to test programmatically
by using unit tests or in
simulator, as well as you
can offer your alpha and beta
environments to the user that
speaks one of these languages,
and see if they can navigate.
And same applies to location.
Today, Nick pointed out
that in simulator, you
are able to change
your location and see
how your action responds back.
And actions on Google offers
multiple functionalities
to developers, like facilitated
payments, account linking,
reengagement, order
updates, push notifications.
Some of these may be hard
to test programmatically.
For example, let's take
payment as an example.
So this may be a
perfect use case
to test with your alpha or
beta testers, and make sure
that they can get
the functionality
that you want to be.
And last but not
least, our action
may be touching
into multiple stack.
So Trail Blazer
rebuilds not only
have Dialogflow and
Assistant on the client side,
but we also built
our own server.
So it's important to make
sure and handle all the cases
in each of these stacks
in the architecture.
NICK FELKER: All right,
so you've designed, built,
and tested your reaction.
Now you've deployed it to users,
but it doesn't stop there.
You have to continue
to ensure that users
have a great experience.
And we have a couple of
tools to help you do that.
The first of which is the
Health Analytics section
in the console.
And this will show you
graphs for the number
of errors that users
are experiencing
as well as the latency.
And we do periodic
checks on your action.
And if we determine
that they are unhealthy,
we'll let you know
over an email.
And if it continues
to be unhealthy,
it will actually be disabled
until it becomes healthy again.
So let's switch
over to the demo.
So here we are in
the analytics page.
You can jump over to Health.
And here's the errors
that are happening.
And let's go ahead and
jump to over the last three
months, what kind of
errors have we had?
All right, and
you see that there
are a couple of errors that
started out a few weeks ago.
We can go ahead and look at
the errors themselves-- invalid
response, timeout,
unknown error.
And we can learn a little more
about why these errors might
be happening.
We can also filter these
out and see, OK, well,
people might be having a
different experience on a phone
compared to a Google Home.
And it seems like
all these errors
relate to mobile devices.
We can also look at the latency.
And you see for 50%
of users, they're
getting about 200 milliseconds.
And that's a pretty
good response time.
As we jump out towards
the 95th percentile,
it gets a little higher.
And so we want to see
what kinds of things
are happening for
some of those users
to help reduce that latency.
And there's more graphs as well.
Now, the second part in making
sure you have reliable action
is Stackdriver.
And to show you how
to do that, I'm going
to go back to the simulator.
And we talked a little bit
about finding bike trails.
But there's also a
bug in our action.
So if I say, give me a tip.
It's actually going to crash.
And that's intentional
for this demo.
OK, so it says, final
response must be set.
Now, you might have
experienced this
when you're using the
simulator, but you might not
know what this means.
If you click this
View Logs button,
we're going to jump
directly into Stackdriver,
which is our logging tool.
And it'll show all the things
that happened, all of the logs,
for our action.
We can go ahead and filter
something like errors.
So we'll find all the
errors that have happened.
All right, you see
right now, we just
got this, file
response must be set.
There's a lot of
information here.
But what exactly does this mean?
Well, since we're
using Cloud Functions,
we actually also log what's
happening there as well.
And we have this error
in our Cloud Function.
It says, reference
error trail tips
is not defined at
index.js, line 30.
OK.
Well, let's just
jump over to our code
and figure out what's happening.
OK, index.js, line 30 says--
well, this is actually correct.
OK, so you might see that
there is a syntax error
in our index.js file.
And once you figure out
that this is a problem,
we can go ahead and
make the change.
And we'll do another
Firebase deploy.
And then the next time we run
our tool and do the simulator
or through [INAUDIBLE] testing,
it will work as we expect.
So let's jump back to the slides
and recap what just happened.
So with Stackdriver logging,
you can examine error logs
for your fulfillment.
And you can filter these
logs based on types of errors
and anything else
that might be logging.
And what's really cool is that
no custom code is required.
If you're using Actions on
Google, you get those logs.
And if you're using
Cloud Functions,
you get those logs as well.
AYLIN ALTIOK: Awesome.
So this concludes
our journey today.
So let's review what we
have been doing together.
So it started with Jane.
And Jane had an idea for an
action called Trail Blazer.
She Built that with Dialogflow.
And once she was done with
designing and building,
she moved it to her
simulator, and tested locally
on her device and on the
simulator on the Actions
on Google web.
And then she wrote
her own unit test
by using automated
testing library.
And once it was all
good and tested,
she released it to her
alpha and beta testers
to make sure she
gets a stable action.
And once she got that,
she was able to deploy it
to public, all Assistant users.
And she was able to
grow her audience.
get more engagement.
And throughout this
journey, once her action
was in production, she
was able to monitor it
by looking at the health
analytics in Actions
on Google console, or
Stackdriver logging that
comes out of the box, and was
able to check, and monitor,
and catch the box if her
production users have
been seeing any issues.
So she was able to
fix those, and make
sure her action was healthy.
And as a result,
Jane was able to get
her own five-star actions.
And we want to make
sure that all the tools
and tips we'll share
today would help you
get your own five-star actions.
Thank you so much for coming.
And we would love
to hear from you.
So if you can go and provide us
feedback in this link up here,
we would be so happy.
And also, please visit
actions.google.com
if you want to learn more about
the things we talked today.
And Nick and I will be available
after the session in sandbox
if you have any questions.
And we would love
to hear from you
either through our developer
channels or in person in IO.
NICK FELKER: Yeah.
So make sure you
follow us on Twitter.
And make sure you follow
Actions on Google.
And use the hashtag AoGDevs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]